once a standard way of settling
disagreements duels were not all pistols
at dawn this is a short history of
unusual duels duels between two women
were rare but they did occasionally
occur and one such standoff between a
pair of high society ladies is specially
stands out the duel the princess versus
the countess a disagreement over floral
arrangements the weapons would be swords
to first blood and one more thing they
were to fight topless this duel was
overseen by a Baroness with a degree in
medicine she had seen war wounds become
easily infected due to soiled garments
and advised the duelers to fight
shirtless the noble women fought for
three rounds
this type of duel fought by women and
overseen by women became known as an
emancipated duel and was seen as a
symbol of female liberation the victor
princess
Pauline meta Nick and women's
emancipation this has been a short
history of unusual duels no of other
unusual duels let us know in the
comments